I've been in the conservatorship for 13
years
my voice was muted and threatened for so
long Britney Spears finally broke the
chains of a conservatorship that
controlled her every move for more than
a decade I honestly think you guys saved
my life but before January ended there
was already new drama Brittany and her
younger sister Jamie Lynn were at odds
over her Memoir things I should have
said where Jamie talked about growing up
in Britney's Shadow it doesn't matter
who your sister is it's like my whole
life I kind of felt like I didn't matter
Brittany reacted to that call her daddy
interview in a series of explosive
social media posts Calling Jamie Lynn a
selfish little brat and sent her a cease
and desist letter E.T talked to Janie in
the midst of the Scandal where she told
us she's still healing from her own
trauma you talk at one point about
Britney being paranoid and getting a
knife and bringing you into a room with
her
how scary were those times for you I
think there was a lot of
things that happen in my childhood that
were very scary and unsafe and I just
think that it's important that I was
able to share how I felt in those
moments you're adamant you have not been
involved in your sister's
conservatorship and anyone involved in
this conservative should be in jail I
think that ending the conservatorship is
what my sister wanted so that's what
happened and I support that I never had
any involvement with it I just simply
wanted to be a good sister I think you
have to remember when this
conservatorship came into place I was a
17 year old about to have a baby so I
think I was pretty occupied I was a Teen
Mom all alone trying to figure it out we
do have the same parents and that very
much makes us sisters and I love and
support my sister and I respect her
healing process and however she has to
work through things and all I ask is
that I you know have that same space
because it's important everyone's
process looks different by February it
was Britney's turn to tell all they can
never take away your truth can you
handle mine she reportedly Inked a 15
million dollar book deal and by the time
April rolled around there was even more
reason to celebrate I would love to have
four kids
she let fans know she was expecting a
baby with then fiance Sam escari who was
excited about their upcoming wedding
this is the happiest time of our lives
and we're just enjoying it it's Heaven
from here on out but in early may she
announced she miscarried her miracle
baby
[Music]
but after giving herself time to heal
she turned her Focus back to music in
August she released her first new single
since 2016 slumber party with Elton John
[Music]
it's a clap she manifested all the way
back in 2015 with this tweet and it hit
the top of the charts within hours of
its release hello Sir Elton John we are
like number one in a 40 countries
[Music]
elton's husband David furnish told E.T
what it was like inside the studio and
she was quite quite um specific about
what she liked and what she wanted and
how she wanted to sound and she gave
terrific notes and uh she very very much
in control and embracing her Destiny
which is you know exactly what you want
[Music]